we gotta zoom out because this this
graphic is epic a lot of images in your
book are just Epic on their own is
brilliantly done but this one has uh
famous people
for each of the cards
like the best of yeah uh for you by the
way good for them to be the person yeah
that that it's not that I could have
chosen lots of people for each card but
I think most people would agree you know
that's a pretty fair choice for each
each page and to good for them to be
able you know you crushed it if you can
be the person for your whole 250 year
page so well I noticed you put Gandhi
didn't put Hitler I mean there's a lot
of people gonna argue with you about
that particular last page true yes
you're right I could have I could have
put in I I actually I was thinking about
Darwin there too
um yeah exactly you really could have
put anyone anything about putting
yourself for a second yeah I should have
I should have that would have been
awesome I'm sure that would have
endeared the readers to me from right
from the beginning of the first page of
the book a little bit of a Messianic
complex going on but yeah so the list of
people just you know so these are 250
year chunks the last one being from 1770
to 2020 And So It Goes Gandhi
Shakespeare Joan of Arc Jenkins Khan
Charlemagne Muhammad Constantine Jesus
Cleopatra Aristotle
it's so interesting to think about this
very recent human history that's 11
pages so it would be 27.50 almost 3 000
years just that there's these figures
that stand out and then Define the
course of human history and it's like
the create the craziest thing to me is
that like Buddha was a dude he was a guy
with like
arms and legs and fingernails that he
may be bit and like he likes certain
foods and maybe he got like uh you know
he had like digestive issues sometimes
and like he got cuts and they stung and
like he was a guy
um and he had hopes and dreams and he
probably had a big ego for a while
before he I guess Buddha totally
overcame that one but like
and it's like who knows you know you
know what the myth the mythical figure
of Buddha who knows how similar he was
but the fact same with Jesus like this
was a good guy like to me it's he's a
primate yeah what uh impact he was a
cell first and then a baby yeah and he
was a fetus at some point he's a dumb
baby trying to learn how to walk yeah
like having a tantrum yeah um because
he's frustrated because he's in the
terrible twos Jesus was in the terrible
twos Buddha never had a tantrum let's be
honest the myth the mother was like this
this Baby's great like
wow let's figure something out it just
but I mean this I mean listen hearing
learning about Genghis Khan it's
incredible to me because it's just like
this was some
um Mongolian
you know herder guy who was taken as a
slave and he was like dirt poor you know
catching rats is it you know young teen
with you know defeat him and his mom and
his I think his brother
um and it's just like
the the the odds
on when he was born he was just one of
you know probably tens of thousands of
random teen boys living in Mongolia in
the 1200s the odds of that person any
one of them being a household name today
that we're talking about
it's just crazy like what had to happen
um and for that guy to for that poor
dirt poor herder to take over the world
I don't know so history just like
continually blows my mind like you know
and here's the reason you and I are
related probably yeah no I mean we're
it's it's also that's the other thing is
that some of these dudes by becoming
King by being having a better Army at
the right time you know William the
Conqueror or whatever has is in the
right place at the right time with the
right Army you know and there's a
weakness at the right moment and he
comes over and exploits it and ends up
probably having you know I don't know a
thousand children and those children are
high up people who might be have a ton
of
the species is different now because of
him like if that forget England's
different or you know European borders
look different like like we are like we
look different and because of a small
handful of of people um you know yeah
certainly sometimes I think I'm like oh
you know this part of the world I can
recognize someone's Greek you know
someone's Persian someone's wherever
because you know they kind of have
certain facial features and I'm like it
may have happened I mean obviously it's
that's a population but it may be that
like someone 600 years ago that looked
like that really spread their seed and
that's why the ethnicity looks kind of
like that now sorry anyway